hey everyone it's sarah register nurse
rn.com and in this video i'm going to
demonstrate how to assess vital signs on
an infant so let's get started when
assessing vital signs on an infant you
want to start with the most
non-invasive vital signs first while the
infant is calm and resting
therefore first you're going to check
the respirations followed by the heart
rate
then the temperature the weight the
length the head circumference and then
the chest circumference
before you assess the infant's vital
signs you want to make sure that you
gather your supplies so what you're
going to need is an infant-sized
stethoscope
followed by a measuring tape a
thermometer
a scale and a watch to count with
and you want to make sure that you
sanitize everything that you're going to
use on that infant before and after use
and of course perform hand hygiene
before beginning
first we're going to check respirations
and we're going to do that first while
the infant
is laying here nice and calm so we get
an accurate reading
and a normal respiratory rate in an
infant is about 30 to 60 breaths per
minute
so before we even start counting
respirations we want to look at that
infant and we want to make sure that
they're not in any respiratory distress
so one way we can tell is we can look at
the nose infants love to breathe through
their nose
so we were checking their nostrils and
we're looking for
nasal flaring and if you see that that's
not a good sign
also you want to look at that chest and
you want to look for anything
like chest retractions and what that
looks like it literally looks like the
skin has just been pulled over the ribs
and you can see the ribs very well and
this infant does not have
either of those things in addition you
want to look at the infant's skin color
and make sure it's appropriate for
their skin tone and that you don't see
any signs and symptoms of cyanosis
so to count respirations what we're
going to do is we're going to count for
one
full minute the rise in the fall of the
chest now with an adult you probably
remember that if the rate was regular we
could count for 30 seconds and multiply
by two
well this isn't the case with the infant
you're going to do it for one full
minute
because infants breathing pattern is
irregular
they have what's called periodic
breathing where they'll breathe and then
they'll stop for a second so we're going
to count for one full minute and we're
looking
at that rise and that fall of the chest
and infants like to breathe abdominally
so
if you're having trouble what you could
do is you could lightly
place your hand on the chest and feel
the rise and the fall
but you want to be careful not to
disturb the infant and
get them crying so i'll demonstrate and
i'll count with each rise
and with each fall just to give you an
example so
here we go one two three four
five six seven eight
nine ten so you wanna count that rise
and that fall for
one full minute and then document that
number
so his respirations were 38 which again
is normal because a normal rate is about
30 to 60 breaths per minute
to count the heart rate you want to make
sure that you're using the appropriate
size diaphragm
and bell and we have an infant here so
we're using an infant size
and for an infant who is less than a
month a normal heart rate
is about 100 to 190 beats per minute and
this can vary if the infant is
crying or if they're sleeping now if the
infant is over
one month that heart rate goes down a
little bit the normal ranges and it's
about 90 to 180 beats per minute
so to count the heart rate what we're
going to do is we're going to use the
apical pulse we're not going to use the
radial pulse like how we do
in adults so to find the apical pulse
what you want to do
is you want to find the fourth
intercostal space
now on an adult remember it was the
fifth intercostal space at the
midclavicular line but for an infant
it's at the fourth intercostal space
lateral to the mid clavicular line
so you want to find the clavicle and
then we have the breastbone
and we're going to go down and we're
going to fill in between those little
ribs
and we're going to go to the fourth
space so there's one
two three four and then we're going to
just go lateral to the mid clavicular
line
so we're going to go about right here
and this is about where the apical pulse
is on our infant
and we're going to place our stethoscope
there and we're going to listen
for one full minute now an infant's
heart rate
can have sinus arrhythmia where it's
irregular because their
heart rate is can be affected with the
respirations where their heart rate will
actually speed up
and slow down with respiration so that's
where you want to count for one
full minute now counting an infant's
heart rate can be difficult because it
is
fast and one thing that i have found
that definitely helps me
is i find that heart rate and then i
like tap my
finger along with that heart rate and
count and our infant's heart rate here
is about 142. to check the temperature
in the infant we're going to check it
via the axillary route so we're going to
place a thermometer tip
in the armpit of the infant and i've
already placed the little protective
sheath over the thermometer so a normal
temperature in an infant can vary
anywhere between 97.5 to 99.3 degrees
fahrenheit to take the temperature make
sure that you turn the thermometer on
and then you're going to place the tip
of the thermometer deep inside
the fold of the armpit and then you're
just going to put the arm down
and you're going to wait for the
thermometer
to beep to tell you the reading okay our
thermometer is beeping so it is done
and the reading is 99.1
so we would document this and this falls
within normal range
to obtain a weight on an infant you want
to remove the infant's clothing and any
soiled diaper a dry diaper can be used
so place the infant on the scale and
obtain the weight
here this infant weighs 10 pounds 2
ounces so you'd want to document that
way
and then look at the infant's previous
weights
this patient weighed 8 pounds at birth
and now at this
2 week appointment they weigh 10 pounds
2 ounces so that is a very good
weight gain from their birth weight to
measure length what you want to do is
you want to lay the baby on a surface
that you can mark you'll need a pen for
this
and you may need someone's help to help
you
measure the baby because you're going to
measure from head to heel
so lay the baby back you'll want to put
their head midline
like this and then just mark their head
then you want to take the leg and extend
it
outward like this make sure it's nice
and extended
you have to work with them a little bit
and then mark it at the heel
and a normal length in an infant is
about 18 to 22 inches
and then we're going to gently lift the
baby up
so we're going to measure this and we're
actually measuring this in inches
and the infant is 22 inches
to measure head circumference you're
going to need a measuring tape and you
want one that measures in centimeters
now a normal head circumference in an
infant is about 33 to 38
centimeters and what we want to do is we
want to place
the tape measure around the largest
diameter of
the head so to do that we're going to
place a little bit above the eyebrows
and then we're going to wrap that around
and place it
around the most prominent part at the
back of the head
so let's do that so gently just lift the
head up and put the measuring tape
behind it
and then pull your measuring tape around
move his head a little bit
and let's see what we get
and his head circumference is about 37
centimeters
to measure chest circumference you want
to get your measuring tape again you'll
be measuring this in centimeters
and you're going to take it and use the
nipple line as your guide so you're
going to
wrap it around there and then measure
it and his
is about 36 and this should be about
one to two centimeters less than what
the head circumference was
okay so that wraps up this demonstration
on how to assess vital signs on an
infant and be sure to check out the
other videos
in this pediatrics series